[Música]
[Aplausos]
la fila era impresionante
imagínense por un momento doscientos y
pico de soldados nuevos con apenas
veinte días de instrucción del servicio
militar obligatorio escuchando la voz de
un oficial de la compañía de
comunicaciones 10 que era donde yo
servía
diciendo los 18 que voy a nombrar están
designados a ir a la guerra de malvinas
yo con esos 18 años apenas recién salido
del secundario con un fusil en la mano
cuando escuché mi nombre y un paso al
frente que me llenó el pecho de orgullo
y tuve una rara sensación de mezcla de
patriotismo e ignorancia porque nunca me
puse a pensar si volvería vivo de esa
guerra
hoy en día todavía estoy pensando como
en un minuto te puede cambiar la vida
porque yo quería una vida normal y no la
tuve y no la tengo
rápidamente volvimos a nuestra compañía
para prestarnos a salir para malvinas
esta es la dedicatoria que yo puse en mi
libro que escribí 25 años después en el
2007 me tomo mis tiempos no macerar todo
ese dolor y toda esa experiencia y
metabolizar la para pasarla a un libro
que hace un homenaje a las cartas que yo
recibía desde el continente de mi
familia y de la gente común que escribía
un soldado quizás incluso acá hay gente
que escribió o sus padres escribieron o
incluso sus abuelos así que para mí
víctimas son todos víctima es mi familia
mi familia actual mis padres mi hermano
y todo lo que me conocían
así que bueno volvimos al regimiento y
bueno rápidamente en 48 horas
teníamos que partir
los regimientos generalmente también
tienen una reja que separaban a la
familia de los soldados y abrazarse a
través de una reja es muy difícil casi
imposible los padres agarrados con
fuerzas o hierros y nosotros del otro
lado sin podernos ver y sin podernos
tocar
así que en un momento el camión empieza
a salir y yo me pude acomodar en la
parte de atrás del camión del ejército
que es altísimo seguramente algunos
habrán visto
en fila para una avenida y tuve la
suerte que lo paro un semáforo
cuando me doy vuelta mi mamá es una
cosita así que mide un metro cuarenta y
pico y las madres en los años ochenta no
corrían no existía el running y cuando
yo vi correr a mi mamá casi me
descompongo nunca la vi correr y correr
buscando el camión desesperada y estira
la mano y trae algo que yo para poder
tomar lo tuve que apoyarme en el filo de
la puerta y apoyar el estómago y
haciendo fuerza llegué y me entrego un
llaverito que lo tengo me lo lleva a la
guerra y lo traje y todavía hoy siento
el roce de los dedos de mi mamá
increíble
ese no era un llavero cualquiera tenía
una plegaria una oración para la persona
que viaja
que vuelva bien y que vaya bien y que no
las echen los enemigos y viniendo de la
mano de mi mamá era perfecto
así fue que cuando llegamos a malvinas
lo primero que hicimos fue cavar las
trincheras esperar había unos tiempos
muertos bastante importantes todavía y
las cosas se empezaron a poner más feas
a mitad de mayo
escribir y recibir creo sin dudas que si
la guerra tiene una parte linda es esta
porque como se dice generalmente lejos
muy lejos de las pantallas y la
inmediatez de hoy se escribía en papel
no existía un teclado la letra se dibuja
la letra de la manuscrita y ahí tenías
la actitud permanente de tu familia y
tus amigos
queriéndote de vuelta queriéndote traer
a tu casa
las cartas para los soldados de malvinas
y cualquier soldado en cualquier guerra
del mundo que sea eran fundamentales nos
traigan las alas que estaban en casa los
colores los sabores las voces de mi
familia yo estaba necesitando eso
urgentemente porque no lo tenía entre el
medio y el frío que teníamos dentro de
una trinchera con el barro pasando la
rodilla con la piedra con el arrastrarse
cada carta que a mí me llegó la conserve
en los bolsillos del pantalón de combate
que eran los más grandes me daba terror
dejarlas en la trinchera compañeros míos
lo hicieron y yo nunca lo pude entender
siempre las guardé y siempre las leía
muy despacito para que me durarán más
eran una anestesia que estábamos
necesitando en ese momento para mitigar
tanto dolor estas son algunas de
personas desconocidas que mandaban
fíjense por favor la calidad de la
escritura la expresión que tiene eso
estas cartas son históricas son
originales son las fotos de la sociedad
del 82 me contaban todo lo que pasaba
nosotros nos enteramos por las cartas
vivíamos a través de las cartas
cuando yo escribía en mi casa yo estaba
frente a la bahía de puerto argentino en
un terraplén al lado del mar y me tomaba
una licencia temporaria de unos minutos
porque tampoco te sobra el tiempo en una
guerra y yo miraba a través del mar del
otro lado de la bahía y pensé que había
un puente con una autopista de carriles
de ida y vuelta hacia el afecto hacia el
calor de mi casa hacia la vida que había
dejado acá
entonces mentía en las cartas que
mandaba a mi familia y le decía que
estaba bien que siempre comía que estaba
abrigado y le decía a mi mamá que estaba
lleno de plantas que a ella le gusta no
había una sola
bueno esto para mí me pone sentimental
porque en la trinchera éramos 4
de izquierda a derecha ricardo sergio y
los dos marcelos estos son hermanos que
la vida o la guerra me regalaron no que
loco que una guerra te regale hermanos
pero así es porque cada uno de nosotros
dependía del otro y estaba para dar la
vida por ese otro y en realidad no
teníamos nada en la trinchera nunca
tuvimos nada teníamos que robar para
comer pero nos teníamos a nosotros
mismos y éramos uno solo y creo que
hasta el clima nos hizo más fuertes y al
sabernos vulnerables más todavía éramos
absolutamente vulnerables
yo robe para comer
como para vivir un día más y vivi ese
día más para repartir entre los
compañeros a ninguno que encontrara o
robará comida se le iba a ocurrir
comerla el solo sin repartir era una ley
que se había hecho en una noche hablando
en la trinchera eso era ley
así que bueno directamente en puerto
argentino cuando empezaron los
bombardeos desde los buques ingleses la
ciudad era la caja de resonancia de los
bombardeos
desde luego que estiraban directamente
66 misiles recién a el tercero escuchar
la detonación del primero y antes silbar
ese misil contra el roce contra el aire
el miedo era impresionante pero en ese
momento el motor del miedo nos ayudaba a
no quedarnos quietos ya consensuar
dentro de la trinchera como teníamos que
movernos o no
el 14 de junio lunes la guerra termina o
la verdad que no sé si todavía terminó
para mí no
fue el día de la máxima resistencia cómo
se dice los ingleses vienen bajando
desde los montes y yo haciendo guardia
como siempre 24 horas al día sin moverme
hambreados y enfermos pasan miles de
soldados corriendo desesperados
diciéndome ándate se terminó la guerra
volvemos y yo decía que no podía irme de
la guardia la tuve que dejar y volvía al
lugar donde tenía mis pocas cosas en mi
equipo donde nunca tuve ni siquiera una
prenda impermeable
entre el caos y los gritos de todo lo
que estábamos ahí vi una bolsa
transparente de nylon que llevaba
pastillas de alcohol que servían para
prender fuego y así tener luz y calor a
donde fuéramos yo no sé lo que es
rendirse no sé lo que es estar
prisionero no sé si me iban a fusilar o
si volvían a una bolsa no tenía idea
bueno una vez que hice eso bajé de ese
lugar y un oficial de mi compañía
reunió a una docena de soldados y
alguien trajo estas cintas celestes y
blancas que todavía la tengo creo que
soy el único que la trajo me puse a
repartirlas como si fuera french y
beruti 1810 y cada uno se lo aprendió en
el pecho del abrigo
este oficial tuvo la idea de tomar la
bandera de guerra de la compañía y pedir
un barril de 200 litros de combustible
todos alrededor de ese barril y el
oficial como si fuera una lanza clava
con el asta hacia abajo la bandera para
que se empape la tela y la prende fuego
y todos inmediatamente empezamos a
cantar el himno nacional y yo lloraba
como un chico y nos abrazamos y ese
momento sublime la guerra había
terminado pero la bandera no se
entregaba
para nosotros los de la compañía de
comunicaciones 10 la guerra había
terminado el viernes 11 cuando murió
ignacio maría indigno un compañero
nuestro que estaba solamente a tres
kilómetros en un cuartel de los royal
marino murió en un bombardeo cuando nos
enteramos la guerra para nosotros ya
había terminado y había que después
contárselo a su mamá aurelia que es la
madre de todos y esa era el era hijo
único de madre viuda y no tendría ni que
haber hecho el servicio militar y
falleció
bueno más adelante un retén inglés
nos tomas prisioneros y me empiezan a
buscar cosas dentro de la ropa y yo no
quería entregar nada siempre las cartas
guardadas y el casco opuesto cuando el
inglés me revisa toca acá el pantalón de
combate y saca las cartas que las
conservan unas bolsitas para que no se
humedezca ni se rompan porque siempre
andas arrastrado en el barro y me dicen
perfecto castellano- qué es esto
digo son cartas que me mandó mi familia
y gente desconocida pero me las tenés
que dejar
y ahí se me ocurrió decirle si yo te las
dejo no me voy a acordar quién soy
porque perdí todo acá perdí todo tenía
el fusil te di las municiones ya perdí
todo no sé que me queda no sé qué me va
a pasar por lo menos con las cartas me
voy a acordar quién soy porque va a
estar mi nombre el papel y accedió que
también accedió a dejarme el casco
ya prisioneros
las noches todavía eran más largas en
malvinas y más crueles
y alguien había decidido que todos nos
pareciéramos la piel de la cara quemada
por el viento la ropa hecha jirones
el alma ausente y la mirada perdida así
estábamos nosotros
llegó un momento que volvemos al
continente en el bahía paraíso en el
buque-hospital habiendo jurado la
bandera y arriba el 20 de junio después
de una tormenta tremenda y empecé con lo
que yo llamo primero mi reparación
porque en ese barco volvíamos los más
enfermos
así que traté de ponerme bien
físicamente y empezar a pensar en mi
futuro pero antes de mi futuro
necesitaba inmediatamente un presente
porque yo mi juventud ya lo había
perdido en la guerra entonces me empecé
a reconstruir y empecé a pensar en
meterme en una facultad y buscarme un
trabajo
me aterraba caer en una depresión
profunda casi segura que me iba a
atrapar igual que la niebla en malvinas
te atrapan muchos la muerte los tomo y a
nosotros sólo nos rozó y pudimos volver
creo absolutamente en las segundas
oportunidades yo soy fruto de una
segunda oportunidad pero también cargó
con la culpa del sobreviviente con ese
síndrome que habla de que el que vuelve
sabiendo que otro murió para que yo
vuelva a mi casa a mí me dura todavía y
lo me duele un montón
ya con la transformación empecé a pensar
cómo puedo hacer un homenaje a mis
compañeros caídos y ese 20 de junio al
bajar del bahía paraíso en la patagonia
me prometí volver un 14 de junio a
malvinas y hacer un homenaje a los que
quedaron ahí y junto de 320 rosarios que
con laura mi mujer amorosamente pusimos
el apellido de cada familia y dejamos
ese homenaje
este es el monte harriet eh hay una cruz
de aluminio blanco increíble lo que se
ve atrás es el monte william que es la
montaña perfecta y hay un baúl que se ve
al pie de la cruz de donde uno puede
escribir lo que quiera y dejar un
mensaje al que lo quiera tomar
y desde ese momento siempre pensé y me
puse a pensar que hubieran sido los
soldados que nunca volvieron que no
tuvieron la oportunidad que no van a
llegar a viejos que no van a ver crecer
a sus hijos oa sus nietos no tienen la
oportunidad que tengo yo en esta segunda
vuelta de tratar de ser el mejor esposo
que pueda padre hermano e hijo yo tengo
esa oportunidad y la quiero aprovechar
en homenaje a los que nunca están
muchos de nosotros
tenemos cicatrices nos pasan cosas
pero yo las muestro y las comparto las
mías están acá y acá
en japon mediante el arte preparan los
pedazos y las grietas de algún objeto
que alguna vez tuvo historia y se rompió
uniendo las con hilos de oro y plata
para hacerlas más bellas y más fuertes a
la vez
depende solamente de nosotros de qué
color queremos pintar esos pedazos rotos
para lucirlos con orgullo yo no soy
-estrenada yo sigo batallando todos los
días y toda vez que suena el himno
nacional
vuelvo a mi trinchera con mis compañeros
como si estuviera en un eterno retorno y
vos de qué color quieres pintar tus
cicatrices gracias
[Música]